alderman raymond lopez thanks so much
for coming on um you know we're not
particularly partisan you're a democrat
i don't even know what you think on a
lot of issues but i know that you care
about the people of the city of chicago
who are thrilled uh to learn that you're
running for mayor
what are you going to do if you win
thank you tucker you know i believe in
the greatness that is chicago but
clearly this is not the chicago that i
grew up in you know i did not grow up in
a city that coddles criminals that
enables bad behavior and turns a blind
eye to the plight of victims in our city
that is lori lightfoot
as mayor i will provide a different
direction a sense of leadership and
purpose to the city of chicago that it
hasn't seen in a while you know you have
to support first responders you have to
support our police trying to maintain
law and order you have to rebuild and
grow an economy by expanding
opportunities and allowing businesses to
flourish and not just operating on a
handout driven society and you need to
provide the basics of city services to
make sure people regardless of the
neighborhood they live in have the
services that their taxpayers provide
it's pretty simple when you think about
it but clearly some people like the
current mayor have a problem executing
that plan i will not
well it is pretty simple actually just
like trying to direct the lives of your
people
right i think do no harm
do no harm exactly so but lori lightfoot
did get elected and chicago is not some
backwater it's one of our biggest cities
a very serious place a lot of smart
people
so i'm not quite sure how she got
elected but do you think that you can
beat her
i know that i can beat laurie life but
we have done polls that show that the
general population the voters of the
city of chicago have made a decision on
whether or not she deserves a second
term and overwhelmingly that answer is
no people in chicago want to feel safe
the number one issue in the city of
chicago as your series pointed out is
that crime is out of control it is like
the wild west in the midwest in this
city
they want a mayor who's going to take
charge to take ownership and i vow to do
that i will make everyone's personal
safety whether they live here work here
or come here to visit for vacation my
number one priority mayor lightfoot has
never done that we're lucky if she even
recognizes a victim let alone take
accountability for it i will take
account i will be accountable for the
violence i have stood up to gang bangers
throughout my two terms as aldermen i
have not backed down even when they've
damaged my home
come at me at my house or even made
death threats against me they don't
scare me the way they scare her and i
will stand for my people
yeah
has she called you racist yet
not yet but i'm sure but she hasn't
actually responded to be honest tucker
i'm sure she's trying to figure out how
to attack me because she can't use the
lgbt card against me because we're both
she's a lesbian i'm gay she can't use
the minority card because she's
african-american i'm latino the only
thing she has left is to talk about
issues and we know her policies have
done more harm than good to the city of
chicago and i welcome that debate
yeah well all of us who love chicago
from afar are rooting for you to restore
order to that great city alderman
raymond lopez joining us tonight thank
you
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight